battlefield 2042 has been a hot topic
for gamers this month especially with
the open beta launching with so many
bugs and glitches as well as a
controversial specialist system the beta
was apparently a two month old build of
the game and it's hard to say if it
accurately showed off what we can expect
from all out warfare at launch turns out
dice recently dropped big updates
earlier with the brand new specialist
trailer showing off five new specialists
and their abilities there was also a new
blog post that detailed what they
learned from the community feedback
which we'll bring up again later as we
talk about what adjustments the game
could benefit from still it seems there
will definitely be growing pains for the
game but fingers crossed will get
something worthwhile so let's dive into
just what changes dice is making and
what improvements we think they should
focus on for release day like this video
if you are so inclined and let's break
all of this down
all right let's get this out of the way
because crosstown games are always in a
challenging position on the one hand you
have battlefield using all of the nitro
on their tank for next gen and pc
getting lobbies up to 128 players on the
other hand many xbox one and ps4 users
can't even get the game to properly work
and that's including the lower 64 player
account discussions in the comments
section on youtube or reddit very
although it seems like old gen
definitely gets the short end of the
stick yeah it's possible to hit 60fps on
the ps4 no idea if that extends to the
base ps4 by the way but let's be honest
here the more combat and action on
screen the heavier the strain on your
console that ps4 or xbox one is gonna
have a real hard time and absolutely
sweating if a tornado drops down on you
in game you know lag doesn't help these
things either and i have no idea what
the server tick rate is at the moment
but even just browsing through the
videos of some other creators on here
that i follow watching them get nuked by
teleporting or rubber banding enemies
man there is no world where that feels
good i'm gonna be straight with you i
have no idea how bad it can get on old
gen and how much of that seems to be a
combination of the hardware and the
state of battlefield 2042 servers what i
do know is there are going to be a lot
of pissed off players trying to upgrade
to next gen that can't and they're
pulling their hair out just to get a
full proper match going on their old gen
console when you drop 60 to 70 bucks on
a game the hope is that it actually
works and that just isn't always the
case from what we've seen in battlefield
2042's beta what's even more troubling
is that the clock is ticking 2042 comes
out on november 12th for early access
folks and that's a real tight deadline i
am all for being optimistic and hoping
for the best but there are some very
real issues here and if we're paying
that full price it's kind of our right
to expect something more complete than
what we've seen so far so optimization
is huge for old gen but general
bugginess and glitches need an extra
look even on current gen platforms
thankfully there have already been quite
a few changes to the gameplay based on
feedback but they're not particularly
groundbreaking they're still nice to
hear about though seriously for example
the removal of bunny hopping to exploit
speed boost or reduced vehicle animation
times these are nice changes and it's
also nice to know that we're getting
more tanks per orbital match with eight
total up from four but that is only on
next gen which also kind of underlines
my point these changes are addressing
the minor stuff and they don't really
address the more substantial issues for
the community playing on last gen not to
mention we need solutions that are more
convincing for other issues such as
specialists
reporting for duty yeah this is going to
be the meatiest part of the video
because there is a lot to unpack with
the new specialists that were revealed
and honestly trying to figure out
whether specialists will ever gel with
battlefield's identity it's that's tough
unfortunately i wonder if their
inclusion is one that we will have to
make peace with although it will not be
an easy sell many folks are
to put it lightly
not fans of specialists i mean shoot the
new specialist trailer has been getting
rationed on our channel already any
youtube video or twitch stream that you
watch has had increasingly vocal please
for something to be done about
specialists and dice has done something
kinda see now on the blog post it seems
like dice is convinced that the more
specialists that we have the less upset
the community will be which i'm not so
sure is true they mentioned that issues
with the ui recognizing friend or foe
and a poor ping system were issues
during the beta that most likely limited
us in experiencing specialists the way
that they were originally designed which
is fair and we'll get to that granular
quality of life update soon but i can
tell you right now that to me it wasn't
really the ui or the lack of in-game
comms that made specialists feel like
lone wolves you see specialists
unfortunately take away from the core
idea of a small soldier in a big war
that battlefield games have done so well
in the past we've never been apex legend
style heroes or overwatch characters
with backstories we've always just been
another soldier maybe with a particular
dog tag at first i didn't mind the
specialist really because i took
advantage of mckay's grapple hook and
his character abilities while ziplining
but i've definitely pivoted on the
subject for sure after hearing things
from your guys's point of view in the
comments still i also have more
experience playing other shooter games
so that hero aspect didn't feel foreign
to me but once i settled into my
thoughts a bit and i heard all of your
guys's comments it made more sense just
because that kind of hero style gameplay
is common in other shooters that does
not mean that it belongs in battlefield
alright let's break down how significant
these new specialists are supposed to be
and remember the idea is that with more
specialists we're supposed to have
better team play
i mean okay so on the assault side the
two new ones you have dozer and sundance
dozer looks built like a tank style roll
rather than an assault and has extra
resistance to explosives and a riot
shield to help push through choke points
by reflecting bullets sundance on the
other hand already sounds overpowered
she's the only specialist with the
wingsuit which means traversing through
air and even those tornadoes are going
to be a hell of a lot easier giving a
significant mobility advantage over the
other specialists what's making me raise
my eyebrows though are these smart
explosives not to mention letting anyone
play a sundance and equip whatever
loadout they want isn't even playing as
assault the specialists make the
original classes completely obsolete in
a way they literally even show her using
an lmg alongside different kinds of
smart explosives and just nothing makes
sense anymore i've mentioned in earlier
videos that battlefield is at its best
when there are two things chaotic
battlefield moments that you would only
see in hollywood type movies and a
balanced level of immersion battlefield
1 did this exceptionally well with its
first person animations whenever you
used field guns or clambered from seat
to c in the fighter plane those moments
were perfect in letting your regular
character feel like a maverick or a hero
while remaining unnamed without a padded
backstory specialists flip the script a
bit and haven't done it well from an
immersion standpoint especially when you
see a bunch of folks running around and
none of them actually you know healing
their team one positive note though is
that they have added extended time for
auto heal so you will be at the mercy of
faulk now on your squad more often which
will hopefully get the medics to focus
on heels a bit more speaking of folk and
the lack of medics there weren't any
other medic specialists though you had
the two assault specialists we mentioned
earlier and two new recon specialists in
rao and pake that basically had wall
hacks i'm not kidding rau's ability lets
you kill a hacked target to reveal
enemies in the immediate area which stay
with me here you have to see someone not
shoot them
take the time to hack them hoping that
they don't see you
and
that then you shoot them like it's not
that's not how shooters work
meanwhile pake would highlight anyone
that damaged you but also had an emg x
scanner that literally just showed
hostels in cover who needs pc hacks when
the game is basically giving them to
particular specialists as an occasional
freebie the odds that solo players are
going to load in and decide to gravitate
towards specialists that are overpowered
is extremely high to put it lightly that
does not bode well for trying to
encourage more team play i wasn't
entirely sure if her wall's ability
passes onto squadmates or teammates in
the vicinity because if it does then
yeah that would technically help team
play but that would also just be broken
as hell once again the gameplay as a
solo player is still fun but this is not
call of duty or overwatch it feels the
opposite of what a battlefield
experience should be which prioritizes
squad cooperation being a solo twitch
streamer that can rack up 70 plus elims
per game is great but in conquest it's
squads that make the fights feel
meaningful at the very least i would
like to see some kind of lockout so you
can only have one of each specialist per
squad so no double dipping now they have
confirmed that that lockout will be the
case for the recently announced hazard
zone at the very least but they have no
plans on making this the case for
all-out warfare there's no good solution
here many fans want specialists to be
removed yet a significant part of
battlefield's overall story and identity
involves specialists i have no idea how
this pertains to battlefield portal but
i won't be surprised to see portal
servers that don't allow any specialists
one attempt that dice is making to help
with squad composition is something they
call insertion flow it's basically a
moment before the game where your squad
will be shown your player card which can
be personalized to show off your play
style and flare and the pre-round was
disabled in the open beta which is why
we never saw this but it'll give us a
chance to chat and make changes to the
squad comp before we hit the ground
running now no idea how this will play
out in action but at least there's an
avenue so players don't double up on
their picks which i am all for so as
mentioned a few times earlier this isn't
to say that no positive changes have
been made based on feedback dice
mentioned improvements they made to the
ui improving visibility of enemies
adding more scoring around support
events like healing and so much more
this is good and i hope we hear more of
it you know i really wanted to talk
about power creep and how it can
negatively affect sandboxes but i will
most likely save that for another time
because we've had a lot to think about
this past week it doesn't look pretty
with how close we are to launch i hope
battlefield portal turns out excellent
and will help cushion any growing pains
with all that warfare you know progress
does carry over from portal to the main
game and not to mention hazard zone
looks like it will be its own thing and
not just demo tacked on so you know we
shouldn't sleep on that really if you
had to ask the community to pick one
thing to change from what i've seen i
think it is safe to say they'll save the
specialists at least in the state that
they are currently in but there is one
thing we need to all consider
listen
these devs work hard they're hearing
your voice they're reading your comments
on reddit and scouring youtube for
videos like these and kudos to them it
is not easy listening to critiques on
something you've worked tirelessly on
for god knows how long what i'm saying
is having issues with the game is
perfectly fine and if you have
constructive feedback to give absolutely
do so so hop in the comments below go on
the battlefield subreddit and let your
voice be heard but please be mindful of
doing it in a low sodium way if possible
until next time